[موسيقى]
اهلا انا عبيد الله العيسي وهذه حلقه
جديده من بود كاس المرتد الذي ياتيكم من
ثمانيه حلقه تاتي بعد ختام مشاركه المنتخب
السعودي في كاس امم اسيا بعد خساره امام
المنتخب الكوري في مباراه مثيره جمعتهم في
دور ال مباراه تفاصيل بسيطه جدا غيرت
مسارها من فوز المنتخب السعودي الى تعادل
المنتخب الكوري ومن ثم خسارتنا بركلات
الترجيح في هذه الحلقه اناقش انا والعزيز
بندر المشرافي اللي صار في المباراه واللي
صار في البطوله وهل بالفعل ارائنا واحكام
تجاه المنتخب وتجاه المشاركه تتاثر
بتفاصيل بسيطه جدا لو لم تحدث ممكن الكلام
والطرح يكون ايجابي ومختلف تماما ايضا
تحدثنا عن روبرتو مانشيني عن المرحله وعن
المستقبل للمدرب الايطالي مع المنتخب
السعودي اللي اعتقد ان مشاكله هي اكبر
بكثير من ان تختزل في تغيير او قرار لاعب
او قرار مدرب بودي ان اشكر رعاه هذه
الحلقه شركه صفا تطبيق محلي اما الان
نترككم مع الحلقه مساك الله بالخير ابو
عاليه مساء النور والسرور يا اهلا ابتسامه
جميله هذه تحس انك كذا ما كان طلعنا
وخسرنا قبل 50 ثانيه من من نهايه المره
ولكن احتراف على قولتك دائما ابو عاليه
الواحد يعني خلينا نقول شاف في الكوره
كثير
فبالتالي احيانا منعرجات الكوره احيانا
تكون لك واحيانا تكون عليك
و يعني خلينا نقول في كثير من المباريات
من الصعب جدا تحليلها لانه ياتي فيها لحظه
اللحظه هذه تعمل فارق تجب ما قبلها توديك
شراط اضافيه سيناريو جديد بعدين بنتيان
فيصير اي كلام عن
الايجابيات يعني يمحى او ينسى هذ خليي ابو
عالي اسالك سؤال كذا خلينا نقول فلسفي شوي
قديش قديش فعلا اراء الناس وجهات نظرهم من
محللين من
جمهور يؤثر عليها المشهد النهائي او
النتيجه النهائيه للمباراه تقدر تعزل رايك
عن نتيجه المباره ما اعتقد ان في كثير من
الناس خصوصا على الصعيد الرياضي كره القدم
تحديدا يقدر يعزل النتيجه النهائيه عن عن
ال عن عن رده فعله او او خلينا نقول رايه
تجاه المباراه ليش لان كره القدم او سياق
اتجاه كره القدم باتجاه انها لعبه تجاريه
صارت تمجد الفائز الفائز يعطى مكان ممكن
يكون ما يستحقه نظير اللي قدم في الم ياخذ
كل شيء هو في كل شيء كل شيء يدخل فيه
المال تحديدا مو كل شيء كل شيء يدخل فيه
المال لك ما تسوي الشيء هذا مثلا في
عائلتك مثلا لو واحد اخطا او عمل اخطاء
كثيره ابنك عمل اخطاء كثيره مسو شي صحح
واحد ما تمحي كل الاخطاء الليي سواها
فلذلك هي مرتبطه وعاطفيه طبعا كره القدم
يعني لعبه بشكل عام تد حول العاطفه وهذا
يخليها دائم ظالمه في الحكم على اشياء
تحكم على شيء معين في الرياضه او حتى في
على طول 9 دقيقه تكون ظالم قياسا بالشيء
اللي شفته في ارض الملعب يعني تشوف 90
دقيقه فريق مسيطر تلقي واحد يخسر بس بشكل
عام هي هي مر حلاوه الكوره جمالها انها
فيها هاللحظات اللي حلاوه وها ومرارتها في
كونها ممكن في لحظه ما ان كل شيء يتغير
ابو عالي قبل ما اتكلم عن المباراه وبكل
ما فيها خلينا نتوقف عند اللحظه اللي غيرت
المباراه اللي هو تسجيل كوريا لهدف
التعادل ثواني بسيطه جدا قبل نهايه
المباراه انا اتوقع اني بصمك
وبصدمة
والاضافي الاول والاضافي الثاني يعني 30
دقيقه و 45 دقيقه هنا كل العرضيات اللي
لعبتها كوريا في هالفتره هي خمس عرضيات
بينما في الشوط الثاني فقط كوريا لعبت 30
كره عرضيه في شوط المباراه الثاني لما
لاعبيك ينجحون في انهم يبعدون 29 كوره
سواء اما انهم يشتتها او انهم يسبقون يعني
يتكلم عن التشتيت او حتى ان حارس المرمى
يطلع ويمسك الكوره او حتى ان المهاجم يلعب
الكوره بس حارس المرمى ينجح في ابعادها
وتغلط في وحده هذا يبين لك قديش انه في
كره القدم ممكن للحظه واحده من فقدان
التركيز او لحظه واحده من ارتكاب الاخطاء
انها تغير من مسار مباراه الناس تحب لما
تصير اللقطه اللي تقلب المباراه انها تبدا
خاصه لما تكون عليك انك تبدا تاخذها
وتفككها وتحللها وتقول هذا ليش ما غطى
وهذا ليش ما راقب وهذا ليش ترك فراغ بينما
فعليا 30 عرضيه اللي لعبوها المنتخب
الكوري في شوط المباراه الثاني كنا نرتكب
اخطاء بس واحد من الاخطاء يشيل احمد
الكسار واحد من الاخطاء يزلق علي حسان
تمبكتي ويجيبها واحد من الاخطاء يجي في
العارضه الاخطاء دائما موجوده بس في لحظه
ما واحد من الاخطاء هذه لا يجد من ينقذه
الكره كانت عرضيه جيده منهم بعدين اللاعب
الثاني رجعها بعدين مهاجم
سجلها لو والله عبد الرحمن غريب وفق في
انه يمنع العرضيه الاولى لو سعود عبد
الحميد ما كان مره متقدم عرفتي تتكلم احمد
كسار ل ما طلع تبدا تتكلم في تفاصيل
المشهد هذا فعليا ترى يصير في اجزاء من
الثانيه اذا بتتكلم تقول احنا نبدو كمان
قاعدين نبسط الامر لكن فعليا كره القدم
اليوم وهال البطوله اسيا
تحديدا جزء منها هي خطط مدربين وافكار
مدربين ب شكل فني لك انت في الملعب شلون
اوقف شلون ادافع هذا ممكن 80 دقيقه 85
دقيقه لكن يظل دائما فيه اخر خمس او ع
دقائق لما فريق يحطك تحت الضغط ويبدا
يهاجمك كوره ورا كوره هذه من اكثر المحكات
اللي يا تنجحك يا تنزل بك يعني وفي
منتخبات وانديه كثيره جدا ترى ضاعت منها
بطولات في كشار اتلتيكو مدريد مع ريال
مدريد لحظه غياب تركيز واحده في واحده من
الركنيات اللي شالوا غيرها كثير غيرت مسار
المباراه وغيرت التاريخ وغيرت مسار ريال
مدريد ومسار اتلتيكو في دوري ابطال اوروبا
خلال العقد الماضي فهذا هذه هي كره القدم
يعني صح ان السيناريو اللي صار يزعل يضايق
بس اتكلم انا عن نفسي لما خلصت المباراه
شعور يزعل بس انه هذه الكوره هذه الكوره
يعني ايام لك وايام عليك بس نهايه الامر
هذه الكوره يعني انا جزت كذا اشوف
المباراه واتذكر كل لحظه في المباراه وكل
دقيقه او كل عمليه تعاطي مع احداث
المباراه اثناء المباراه في اشياء دائم ما
يتم التركيز عليها الا لحظه ما تكون خسران
وهذا الشيء يخلي دائما لانتصار الف والد
والخساره طفل واحد يتيم يتحملها هو ليس
دفاعا عن ماشيني او ان الاسلوب اللي بدا
فيه البطوله او حتى هذه المباراه ولكن هذه
لحظه المفصليه دائم حتى حتى مجهود ذات
اللاعبين في ارض الملعب تنهيها يعني خيبري
يقدم واحده من اعظم مبارياته لم تكن
الاعظم على الصعيد الفردي له كشخص لانه
كان في المكان اللي فيه تقريبا زحمه زحمه
لاعبي كوريا وافضل لاعبيه بالضبط افضل
لاعبي زائدا الكسار اللي وضف الى ذلك ان
الخيبري يلعب بطولته الاولى ترى علي جامي
يلعب بطولته الاولى وقدم وده من اجمل
المباريات الكسار يلعب بطولته الاولى وقدم
وده من اجمل المباريات ضف الى ذلك رديف
اللي يلعب بطولته الاولى يسجل ضد ضد كوريا
ليس بالامر الهين او السهل ضف اليهم ممكن
تحط ناصر الدوسري وفي ايضا كم اسم تق
تضيفهم قدموا خلينا نقول بطوله رائعه وهي
اول بطوله لهم على الصعيد الدول حتى
البريك بعد فتره طويله غياب رجع وقدم حده
من اجمل البطولات ولكن يا ابو
علي الخطا او او عمليه الضغط اللي مارسها
المنتخب الكوري علينا لو تلاحظ في لحظات
ها كان الفريق يحاول ان يطيح يقت المباراه
الين جت فتره من الفترات ما قدرنا نطلع
الكرهه وحتى لما نطلع الكره تطلع تشتيت
يعني وكاني بس ابعد الكره ابعد مكان ممكن
ثم التفت على اخوياي ا
تقدم وهذا يرجعني سؤال وسمعت انا تصريح
علي البليه بعد المباراه لما سول هل
التراجع هذا المخيف اللي انتم عملتوه هل
كان تصريح هل كان تكتيك مدرب او ان انتم
سويتو بانفس بسبب ضغط الكوري فقال انه
بسبب ضغط الفريق الكوري وخليك ترجع شوي
خطوه للوراء
وتشوف قديش المشكله الاعظم على المنتخب
السعودي في هذه البطوله كانت واضحه في ذ
العشر دقائق المس باص اللي كنا نتكلم عنها
انا واياك يا ابو علي طوال فتره البطوله
في عمليه فقدان للكوره عدم
ثقه ما ادري ايش تسميها صراحه بس تحس
اللاعب هو ز الكرهه وهو في عمليه ضغطه او
مارس عليه لا كور ضغط خاف يرتبك فيلعب باص
خطا وهي صارت كثير يعني ولا لاعب ولا
لاعبين ثلاثه وبرضه انا اعزيها شوي برضه
اللاعب الثاني اللي بيفتح معك ما يفتح
فتحس انه كذا ما في ذاك اللاعب اللي في
النص اللي اذا تورط اي لاعب ادبها له اطمن
عليها واقول خلاص هي في ايدي امينه ما
فيذا اللاعب موجود ومشيني ارتكب اكبر خطا
في اللحظه اللي هو فريقه من بدايه البطوله
عنده مباس كثيره في اللحظه اللي فريق
اثناء المباراه عليه ضغط كبير في اللحظه
اللي فوتوا كور كثيره مس باص دخل علي عيد
المولد
وحرفيا ظلم اللاعب يعني حطيته في موقف
صراحه يعني عرفت كيف الواحد اللي اذاذا
حطك في مكان قدامك جيش وراك وادي حرفيا
انا بالحالي ذحين والناس كلها تشوفك وانت
باللي لعبت مباراه الاخيره ضد تايلاند
عشان تقول اوكي ادخل اجواء البطوله لا ما
لعبت منكن لعيب القلائل اللي ما لعب او ما
شارك ولا دقيقه في البطوله تروح تنزله في
هذه المباراه ضد خصم مثل كوري وعندك في
الدكه مختار علي اللي قادر يكون هادي على
الكوره بصاته جميله اخذ تجربه اكبر عندك
عبدل المالكي اللي عنده تجربه كبيره وضخمه
في كاس العالم قدم مستوى فيها رائع لعب
مباراه في البطوله نفسها فرما حرفيا كك
رميتها في النار وادى يعني اداء المودي
لومه لاعب صغير في السن مباراه كبيره عليه
بس تشعر انه كان يعني تبديل لموقف اكبر
منه بس ابو علي لو ترجع الى شوط المباراه
الاول المنتخب الكوري كان يركز بشكل كبير
جدا انه يلعب دائما الكرات في ظهر حسان
تمبكتي يعني من الشوط الاول كان يلعبها
طويله لما كان دفاعنا يلعب متقدم فيلعب
دائما في ظهر المدافعين وتحديدا كان منفذه
من ناحيه اليسار في ظهر حسان لما بدا
مدربهم يغير في شوط المباراه الثاني من
اول التغييرات اللي سواها هنا نزل هوان
لاعب رقم 11 لاعب وفر هامبتون ولعبه ناحيه
الطرف الايسر وغير طريقه اللعب الى 4 2 3
1 فعمل زياده عدديه على الجهه اليمنى
للمنتخب قد تكون فكره مانشيني انه بحث عن
لاعب يقدر يعمل التامين ولو تلاحظ ان
هدفهم جاء من ذاك المكان اللي هي الراسيه
الاولى اللي بعد كذا رجعت الى داخل البوكس
وكانت معظم اختراقات الكور اللي على الارض
كانت من الجهه اللي موجود فيها حسان بذلك
ممكن يبرر للمدرب اذا في خطا يا ابو عاليه
ممكن ينقال عن خطا معي ارجع واقول ان احنا
نتاثر كثير بنتيجه المباراه ليش العرضيه
اللي جاء منها الهدف الاولى اللي طلعت من
لاعب ظهير الايم من حقهم لو ان هو طبعا
ظهير يمين لف وخذاها باليسار قدما ضعيفه
لو موفق لو طالت لو طلعت برا ترى اليوم كل
اللي احنا قاعدين نقوله ما راح نتكلم عنه
لكن لما يصير في خساره نبدا ندور على
اسباب والفكره اللي لما تفوز هي ناجحه
تتحول الى نقيض ذلك ليش في شوط المباراه
الثاني ماشيني كل الخيارات اللي نزلها هم
لاعبين يجمع بينهم صفه مشتركه واحده انهم
عدائين يركضون سريعين ماهم كويسين على
الكوره مو كويس انه يحافظ على الكوره تحت
الضغط ممكن مهاري زي عبد الرحمن غريب ممكن
عنده حلول على مستوى الانهاء زي عبد الله
رديف بس عبد الله رديف وعيد المولد وعبد
الرحمن غريب القاسم المشترك بينهم ان ان
اذا الموضوع فيه سرعات الثلاثه كلهم
كويسين اذا الموضوع في يتطلب جهد بدني
وافر وجري قطع مسافات الثلاثه كلهم كويسين
لكن العيب انه ولا واحد منهم كويس يوقف
على الكوره يعني افضل واحد عندك كان ممكن
يوقف على الكوره هو سالم انت بدلته صالح
الشهري اللي ممكن ياخذ المدافع في ظهره
سواء انه ياخذ الكوره ويدور فيها او يتسبب
لك في فاول انت كمان طلعته فبالتالي كانت
الازمه انا في ظني ما هي في الكوره اللي
سجلتها كوريا الازمه في انهم لعبوا 30
كوره عرضيه في شوط واحد هذا رقم مرعب هذا
رقم عاده الانديه ترى تلعب 30 عرضيه في
مباراه من 90 دقيقه لانك انت استقبلت
اللعب اكثر م ما ينبغي ليش استقبلت اللعب
اكثر من ما ينبغي الحين علي بلايه يقوللك
ان المدرب ما اعطانا التعليمات انت لما في
فريق قاعد يضغطك زين عندك حل من الاثنين
لا ثالثه لهم عشان تبعد الكره عن مرماك يا
اما انك تلعب دفاع متقدم تقول انا برهن
على مصده التسلل فبالتالي تبغون تضغطون
انا بطلع دفاعي بس المشكله هنا ايش ان اي
كوره ورا دفاعك هي بمثابه بمثابه انتحار
وانت تتكلم عن زياده عدديه موجوده عندهم
عندهم سون وكج لي كلهم اجنحه اذكياء في
عمليه التحرك في ضرب مصيده الدفاع وهذا
خيار مستبعد عند كثير من المدربين الحل
الثاني انك انت تعرف توقف على الكوره يعني
لما تاخذ الكوره تحاول انك تقتل الريتم
بشيء غير انك تطيح و يعني تدع الاصابه
وتحاول انك تقتل الرتم انك تسيطر عليها
تطلع بالكوره على الطرف تحد اللاعب من
يطلعها اوت او ان يطيح فبالتالي تاخذ وقتك
على الاوت او او على الفاول لكن لما ما
يكون عندك لاعب كويس بالكوره هنا هنا هنا
تصير المشكله ترى المنتخب الكوري في شوط
المباراه الاول اختار انه ما يضغط على
دفاعنا وكان يسمح لمدافعين انهم يتبادلون
الكور ويطلعون فيها الى منتصف الملعب
الشوط الثاني والا شواط الاضافيه لما قرر
انه يضغط علينا كلنا شفنا كيف عانا حسان
تمبكتي وعلي لاجامي وبقيه مدافعين فانهم
يطلعون الكره من تحت الضغط اتكلم تتكلم عن
المدافع اللي موجود في مساحه اكبر وش انت
قايل عن لاعب الوسط قدرك ان هذا الجيل من
اللاعبين السكواد اللي موجود عندك اليوم
عندهم عده مزايا يعني الكرات الثابته اللي
انت تكلمت عنها وعاليه حل مهم ومنتخبنا
كان قاب قوسين اد انه يسجل منه هذه ميزه
لك تكلم على مستوى الجانب اللياقي منتخب
هذا واحد من افضل منتخباتنا على الجانب
اللياقي على مستوى السرعات من افضل
منتخباتنا لكن هذا المنتخب عنده عيب واضح
ان ما عنده لاعب يقدر يوقف على الكوره
والمشكله ان حتى ان حتى لاعبيك اللي
تتراهن عليهم زي كنو وزي عبد الله الخيبري
واضح انه بمرور المباراه بدنيا بداوا ب
بوا ينزلون مره لدرجه انك عبد الله
الخيبري اضطريت انك تغيرها مع بدايه
الاشواط الاضافيه نرجع نقول ابو علي هي
تفاصيل تصنع مسار مباراه وللاسف ان في
كثير من الاحيان يتم اختزال العمل ويتم
اختزال الشغل اللي سواه المدرب واللاعبين
في المباراه من خلال الاقطه ارجع اقولك لو
طال الاوفر الاول ترى ما كنا نتكلم عن ك
اللي احنا قاعدين نتكلم عننا الحين ولكن
سؤال حتى لو عد المنتخب مثل ما ان نقول لو
صار يعني كما لو ان اللي صار يرغي
الاجابيات كمان لو انت فزت لا يغلو انت
عندك سلبيات وعندك اشياء كثيره تحتاج ان
انت تعدلها الفتره
الجايه من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم
ورفاهيه الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول
سكنيه مبتكره ومستدام مع شركه صفا
للاستثمار المزيد في وصف
[موسيقى]
الحلقه
عشر دقائق من صباحك كفيله اطلاعك على ما
يهمك ويعني من احداث العالمي
العجر اخباري وننشر منه حلقه فجر كل يوم
نتكلم فيها عن جديد العالم من احداث
واخبار ونشرحها ضمن سياقها من تاريخ
تطورها كل يوم بيومه كل خبر بوقت بكاست
الفجر متوفر على جميع منصات البودكاست
اشترك وتابع
الجديد يعني ما في فريق بطل او فريق يحقق
لقب بابو علي يكون دائم صح ودائم وما عنده
اخطاء في نهايه الامر الكوره وارد فيها كل
شيء يعني يتذكر في تجربه الارجنتين في
بطوله كاس العالم الماضيه تررى مر في
السين يشبه السين اللي مرينا فيه ضد منتخب
هولندا وحتى في النهايه ضد صحيح ضد فرنسا
يعني نفس السيناريو بالضبط ان تستقبل هدف
في اخر دقيقه بس ترجع يكون يحسب صراحه
اللعيب انك ترجع تاخذ هدف في اخر دقيقه
وتركيزك ما فقدته ذهنيا ولا نهرت اثناء او
بعد مع الاشواط الاضافيه رغم ان الفريق
تحسه بدنيا وقت ما ب اشواط اضافيه تحس انه
تعبان كان يبغى المباراه تخلص والدقيقه ذ
تنتهي ويروح للدور الثاني او المباراه
الثانيه وهنا يجيني سؤال انا ما اعرف هل
هو السؤال الصح في التوقيت الصح او السؤال
الغلط في التوقيت الغلط بس افكر في
المستقبل يعني هل مانشيني هو رجل المستقبل
في المنتخب السعودي هل ماشيني بهالطريقه
هذه بالاسلوب هذا بطريقه تعامل مع
اللاعبين الجيل اللي جالس يحاول يصنعه هل
هو رجل مستقبل واذا كان هو رجل
مستقبل يجيني كده تساؤل ثاني كيف انك تصنع
كل هال التغييرات الضخمه والكبيره في اول
فتره لك يعني انا ممكن ارجع شوي خطوه ورا
واقول انه بعد ما مشى ايرفي رينارد جلسنا
تقريبا 150 يوم بدون مدر وهذا طبعا اتوقع
انه من اكبر الاخطاء اللي اللي عانى منها
المنتخب السعودي على مستوى يكون عنده مدرب
يبدا يتاقلم مع المجموعه ويشوفها ويعرفها
من وقت مبكر خصوصا عندك بطوله تقام في او
بعد ع اهور كان تسع اشهور ما كان في ذاك
الوقت الكبير ت 150 يوم بدون مدرب ثم
بعدها تيجي ماشيني قدام 140 يوم علشان كاس
اسيا ولما يجي يصنع هالكم الكبير جدا من
التغييرات في وقت قياسي بطوله كاس العالم
تقام 2026 بعدها بسنه تقام اسيا اي ان اذا
تبغى تسوي
مرحله تغيير ضخمه وكبيره في المنتخب
الوطني ما تكون لا ما تكون بين البطولتين
هذه يعني ما في وقت يعني كافي انك تعمل
هذا التغيير الكبير ممكن منك المنتخبات
اللي عملت تغيير ضخم وكبير في اسيا على
مستوى الاسماء اللي عندها من كاس العالم
الى الى بطوله امم اسيا اليابان لانه كان
الجيل اللي لعب كاس العالم تقريبا نوم
كبير المدافع يشيده يشيده برضه متقدم في
العمر 35 فما كان يقدر يعطيك اب بعد من
كذا الحارس حقهم برضه ماك كان سن متقدم
فكان مرحله اقدر اقول لك اعمل فيها
التغيير وهم يملكون خلينا نقول قائمه
اسماء كثيره مش عناصر او مو مثلنا عناصرنا
او سكواد اللي تملكه الكوالتي العالي منه
مو مو متوفر فتغيير كانت 15 او 15 اسم من
شارك كاس العالم لعبوا هذه البطوله
المنتخب 12 اسم فقط من لعبوا كاس العالم
لعبوا هال البطوله وهنا يقول يعني هل كان
هذا هو التوقيت المثالي انك تسوي هذا
العمليه كبيره في التغيير او انك كنت تقدر
تاخذ جزء من الجيل الثاني او الجيل السابق
ويكون مشاركين في ه البطوله ويعطونك شويه
بعد اكثر خبره يعني انا ممكن اللحظات
الاخيره هذه ما في شخص او رجل في الملعب
يقدر يتحكم لي فيها الا واحد عنده تجارب
يعني واحد لعب مثل ه المباريات لعب تحت
ضغط كبير لعب نفس الموقف هذا اني مضغوط
وفي حاله صعبه زي صارت معنا ضد منتخب
الارجنتين في كاس العالم يعني انا ك قاعد
اذكر ذك المباراه على طول لان كنا لعبت
المباراه دفاع متقدم ارجنتين وفي اخر ع
دقائق او ربع ساعه كان الفريق كله كله صفه
ونشوت الكره لابعد نقطه ممكنه فقعد تذكرني
بذاك السيناريو هل كان هو التوقيت المثالي
اذا كان فعلا التوقيت المثالي وانك ضحيت
بهذه البطوله هل انت رهانك على ماشيني هو
الرهان الصح هل ماشيني هو الرجل اللي ممكن
ياخذ هذه المجموعه وبداها بمشكله ونهاها
بطريقه خروج انا من الناس اللي احب ماشيني
ترى ودني يكمل مش الناس ممكن تنظر لانه
خلاص طلعنا لازم ماشيني يطلع
ونقضي خلاص لا انا ودي اني اكمل لانه صنع
خلنا نقول تغيير فتره قصيره بس هل كان هذا
التغيير وقته
مثالي ما اعتقد صراحه انه كان كان مثالي
جدا من من اداره الاتحاد من الاتحاد
السعودي وحتى من من ماشين نفسه خلينا نرجع
ابو عاليه الى ظهيره مباراه السعوديه
والارجنتين وتذكر التشكيله اللي لعب فيها
المنتخب السعودي في ذك المباراه محمد
العويس وغير موجود مع القائمه حاليا لانه
مصاب ماشين م ذنب في الموضوع قلبي الدفاع
حسن تمبكتي علي البليهي موجودين معه ظهير
الام السعود عبد الحميد موجود معه ظهير
الايسر ياسر الشهراني في كلام يعاني من
اصابه وياسر في تراجع كبير جدا في مستواه
تروح الوسط عبد الاله المالكي موجود محمد
كنو موجود ممكن الاستبعاد الوحيد هو سلمان
الفرج قدام كان في سالم صالح الشهري فراس
براكان ثلاثه كلهم موجودين معه صح انت
تاخذها ك قائمه من 26 لاعب في اسماء يمكن
كثيره ابعدها بس العمود الفقري وجل
العناصر المنتخب اللي كان موجود مع رينارد
لازال موجود اليوم مع مانشيني فما اعتقد
انه غير كثير على مستوى العناصر نجي الشق
الثاني اللي هو تغيير الافكار تحديدا
طريقه اللعب والمنهجيه اللي انت قاعد
تعتمد عليها انت ما انت جاي في موسم رياضي
فجاي في وسط الموسم فتقول انا والله صعب
اني اغير او احتاج اني ابني على نجاحات
المدرب السابق انت ما عندك حصص تدريبيه
كثير فبالتالي تحتاج انك من البدايه تحط
اسلوبك لانه انت ما عندك رفاهيه معسكر
اعدادي في الصيف ولا عندك رفاهيه انك تلعب
كل اسبوع مباراه فبالتالي بتشاهد تطور
مباراه بعد مباراه فتقول اوكي يلا خليني
اكمل على نمط المدرب السابق وببدا اغير في
وقت لاحق انت تحتاج انك من البدايه انك
تحط بصمتك مع المنتخب خب وفي ظني انا ما
اعتقد صراحه ان الاسلوب اللي لعب فيه
مانشيني سواء فكره الثلاثه المدافعين او
حتى فكره انك انت مثلا ما تضغط عالي تلعب
ميديم بلوك تدافع من وسط الملعب تلعب على
رده الفعل اكثر ما اعتقد انها هي اللي
صنعت الفارق بشكل كبير في في نقطتين انا
اعتقد
انها هي مشكله قديمه جديده بالنسبه لنا من
زمان قاعده تظهر وظهرت حتى في كاس
العالم الماضي الاولى ان احنا على الجانب
البدني
[موسيقى]
واللياقية بس لازم تتوقف عند نقطه ان محمد
بريك تغير بسبب اصابه حسان تمبكتي بسبب
اصابه وعبد الله الخيبري بسبب اصابه ناهيك
عن لاعبين اللي تحامل على انفسهم عشان
ينهون المباراه ولاعبين اصلا كان واضح لنا
زي علي لاجامي ومحمد كنو ان اداءه بدا
يتغير ويتراجع في المباراه لانه بدنيا ما
عاد قادر انه يعطيه بالمقابل هل جاك شعور
ان المنتخب الكوري عانى ليقين وبدنيا
امامنا هل شفت لاعب يتغير اضطراريا هل شفت
لاعب هل شعرت ان سون ولا كان جلي ولا اي
واحد اداءه في الاشواط الاضافيه ولا على
نهايه الشوط الثاني اقل من اداء اللي كان
في شوط المباراه الاول بالعكس لما كل ما
وقت المباراه يمر كل ما تحس انهم هم
واقفين على رجولهم اكثر منا فهذه مشكله
واضحه من كاس العالم الى امم اسيا حاليا
ممكن ترى لو عدينا في مباراه كوري ك مدفع
الثمن في مباراه استراليا انه لا يزال
هناك فارق بدني واضح بينك وبين بقيه
النقطه الثانيه تشعر ان على شان نكسب في
كاس العالم او حتى في مشاركتنا الحاليه في
كاس اسيا نحتاج دائما الى سيناريو واحد
وسيناريو مثالي وانا قلتها بعد مباراه
الارجنتين لو واحده من الكور اللي احتسب
التسلل على لاعبهم بفضل يعني تقنيه الفار
كان متاخر اللاعب سنتيمتر واحد تركن ما
كان كسبنا ذيك المباراه يعني انت احتجت
الى ان السيناريوهات تكون مثاليه وفعليا
في ذيك المباراه امام الارجنتين سددنا
دتين جبنا منها هدفين وكنا موفقين في ان
الارجنتين اضاعت ذاك الكم من الفرص امام
بولندا جت يمكن فرصه واحده في المباراه
اللي هي البلنتي اللي ضيع سالم ومن ثم
خسرنا المباراه يعني تحس ان المباراه يا
تمشي معنا ولا غلطه يا ان ما راح نكسب
وانا ما اقولها اتكلم عن جانب الحظ اتكلم
عن جانب انك انت كيف تتشكل مع ظروف
المباراه المنتخب الكوري بدا 3 ا 3 نفس
الاسلوب اللي احنا نلعب فيه او 3 خ
ا ما مشت الامور عنده حلول على مستوى
الدكه غير النظام الى 4 2 3 1 هو بادي
مباراه بسون وتحته كان جلي عنده مهاجم
ممتاز زي رقم تسعه موجود في الدكه حل عنده
هوان لاعب جناح ايسر حل عنده عده حلول
يقدر انه يغير من اسلوبه وم شكله ولما
ينزلهم كلهم ويحطك تحت الضغط في اخر
الدقائق يقدر انه يؤذيك تخيل ابو عاليه
السيناريو العكس ان كوريه تقدمت علينا
واحنا احتجنا ان في اخر دقائق المباراه ان
نحطهم تحت الضغط وعلى قوله اب ورد نرش
عرضيات هل لديك لاعبين جيدين في في
العرضيات هل لديك ضاربي راس تكلم متغيرت
صالح الشهري قل والله بنزل في راس بركان
مع عبد الله رديف هل تقدر تراهن على
الاثنين امام دفاع كوريا في انهم بيعطونك
حلول راسيه هنا واضح ان المنافس لديه قدره
على انه يتشكل مع ظروف المباراه ولديه
قدره على انه يملك حلول من الدكه بينما
انت تحتاج دائما الى ان المباراه كما لو
انك راسم لها سيناريو واحد ان مشت عليه
انا فست ان صار اي تغيير مفاجاه في الخطه
انا انا انا بتورط وحتى لما رات المباراه
ل شواط اضافيه كان شكلنا داخل الملعب
معنويا وتركيز اللاعبين نفسيا وذهنيا كان
واضح انهم اقل بكثير من لاعبي المنتخب
الكوري و حتى حصلت لهم انفراده لوفق في
تسجيلك المباراه حتى ما كانت راح تروح
لركلات الترجيح تعال ركلات الترجيح نفسها
يعني انت الاربعه اللي موجودين المنفذين
عندك كل واحد منهم ليس منفذ اول على على
مستوى نادي يعني يمكن كانو فاجا الحارس
بالتكتيك جورجيني واللي سواه سعود عبد
الحميد لعبها مفاجاه في زاويه فوق اثنتين
اللي ضاعت وان ما اتكلم هنا عن اللاعبين
اي لاعب ترى ممكن يضيع بس انت كانت سهله
بالنسبه للحارس بينما لاعبي كوريه شافوا
الاولى الثانيه ان حارس مرمانا قاعد يروح
مع كل كوره غيروا في تكنيك او طريقه
تعاطيهم مع مع التنفيذ ليش تتكلم عن لعيبه
خبره لعيبه جايين من اوروبا من اقوى
الدوريات يتمرنون مع افضل اللاعبين
فبالتالي حط كثير في في هالموقف التشكيله
اللي لعبنا فيها الاشواط الاضافيه معظمهم
لاعبين يا ابو عاليه امهم قليلي الخبره او
انه زي ما قلت هذه مشاركتهم الاولى يعني
الشوط الثاني علي لجامي اول بطوله يتم
الاعتماد عليه فيها بشكل اساسي عون
السلولي نفس الكلام عيد المولد نفس الكلام
مين كان موجود سامي الخيبري ممكن شارك
اعتقد شارف كاس العالم اذا ما كنت مخت
سامي النجعي عبد الله رديف معظم عناصرك هي
ناصر قليله الخبره فبالتالي انت لا تزال
عالق في نفس مشاكلك القديمه بدنيا تحتاج
تتطور اكثر على مستوى جوده العناصر لا
يزالون الجماعه افضل منك فبالتالي لا بد
ان نكون واقعيين ترى لو فلتنا اليوم من
كوريا وكسبنا مكلات الترجيح نفس المشاكل ي
بتحط على المحك ضد استراليا وضد ايران وضد
اليابان وضد اي احد انت تواجه انتك فتره
ما تنجح في اسيا بس توصل كاس العالم ليش
لانك تقدر تاخذ نقاط من العراق من عمان من
الامارات من المنتخبات اللي اقل من مستواك
بس لما تجي تلعب مع المنتخبات هذه اوكي
ممكن نكسبهم بس نكسبهم في الذهاب اكسبو
لنا في الاياب متى اخر مره فزنا على
اليابان في اليابان ما عمرنا فزنا على على
استراليا في استراليا متى اخر مره واجهنا
كوريا ظهر تصفيات 2006 اذا اذا ما كنت
غلطان فانت لك فتره طويله جدا ما تقدر انك
تواجه المنتخبات في بطوله مهمه زي اسيا او
تروح تواجههم بدون افضليه الارض والجمهور
في تصفيات كاس العالم لما تكون
المباراه على ارضك وتكسب لا يمكن لهذا
الكم من التعثرات اني اجي واقول سبب
ماشيني سبب هذا التغيير سبب استبعاد
اللاعب لا المشكله هنا
اكبر القضيه هنا اوسع من انك تحصرها في في
سبب بسيط واحنا للاسف نميل دائما ترف
سوالفنا حتى ك تجس تتفرج المباراه مع اي
احد حوالك نميل دائما الى اعطاء مسببات
سهله للخساره اكيد والله لو انه ما غير
والله لو انه ما نزل فلان والله لو ان
صابر على فلان انت اذا تركت المشهد وطلعت
فوق وناظرت
وشفت المشكله بحجمها الحقيقي تكتشف ان
الموضوع لا اكبر بكثير من المسببات
البسيطه اللي انت قاعد تقولها يعني انت
قلت قبل شوي انه كيف احنا نتاهل كاس
العالم للنكس والعراق وعمان اتوقع بعد مو
لكس العراق وعمان والمنتخبات اللي اللي في
مستوانا بقد ما البطوله او المنافسه هاي
تلعب على مدى سنه سنتين لين تتاهل فما
تكلا وال المباراه اللي معك المباراه اللي
معك مثلا اليابان بتلعب معك في جده
المباراه ذ ما هي حياه وموت بالنسبه له
لانه ممكن يكسف مباراه ثانيه ويتاهل يعني
ما تتكلم زي مباراه اليوم في واحد بيكم
واحد يطلع بقصد انا من هال الجزئيه انه
وهاي صراحه عينا منها في كاس العالم لما
كنا قريبين وكنا نطمح ان نكون نتاهل من
المجموعه ولما الان حاولنا ونطمح ان نوصل
لور الاربعه ا دور او النهائي حتى مباريات
تخان في فتره زمنيه قصيره تحس ان اللاعبين
وقت ما تكون المباراه بدنيه ووقت ما يلعب
برتم عالي 90 دقيقه مباراه المباراه
الثانيه تقي 2 3 مصابين عندك تجي المباراه
اللي بعدها تلقي نفس المشكله 2 3 مصابين
عندك ت مباره بعدها اين عندك وصارت ضد
الارجنتين لما لعبنا ضدها تقريبا ثلاث
اسماء ما كملت ولعبت المباراه التاليه مع
بولندا نفس الكلام بعد مباراه بولندا رحنا
مباراه المكسيك وعندنا كم كبير من
الاصابات لما لعبنا مباراه المكسيك اثناء
المباراه كم لاعب انصاب فتشر العامل
الياقي او اللعيبه بدنيا مو بذاك الكرسي
انا ممكن شوي اروح الجانب انه الياباني
الكوريين عندهم اللاعيب المحترفين اللي
اوريدي هم ب جاهزيه وتعافي بدني بحكم انهم
يلعبون في بطولات تنافسيه ورتم عالي
اللاعب الكوري هو في نهايه موسم والان هو
في الصيف حقه اللي هو صيف كاس العالم فهو
اوريدي لعب الموسم كامل وصل لاعلى حاله
مثاليه له كرياضي لانه بيخلص الكاس اسيا
وبيريح اجازته الشهر وبعدها بيبدا الموسم
الموسم من جديد التحضير الاول بري سيزون
ثم بعدها يبدا السيزون فتوق بالنسبه
لاقامه المنافسه يخدمهم كثير من ناحيه
جوده او العامل الياقي انهم جاهزين لهال
المنافس اضيف للا احنا ما احنا كويسين على
العامل البدني يعني رف رينارد في تجربته
مع المنتخب في كاس العالم اخذ اللعيب ذول
شهرين تقريبا شهرين لقاهم يعني في حاله
بدنيه سيئه هنا يجي عيب انك الان في هذا
الدوري القوي اللي قاعدين نشوفه في في
الدوري السعودي لازم تكون لاعب قوي بدنيا
انت ما تحتاج انك تكون مهاري فنان تعطي
باص حلو تلعب وان الواقف لاز تكون لاعب
بدنيا جاهز عشان تقدر تحتك مع اللاعب هذا
يعني حرفيا الاجانب بكلون في في الدوري
السعودي ماي صراحه علي صراحه يعني بقوللك
على نقطه الجانب البدني اب عاليه اولا
وجود خلينا نقول نوعيه جيده من التمارين
مدربين لياقه جيدين ونظام يحط النادي لا
يعني بالضروره ان كل عناصر النادي بتصير
كويسه يقين يعني ريال مدريد مع بنتس طلع
لك لاعب زي مودريتش عمره حول 40 نشيط يركض
احسن من لاعب في ال بس نفس المدرب ونفس
السيستم هذا يطلع واحد زي هازارد ما يعرف
يركض ع لا ت 10 متر هي تعتمد على سلوك
اللاعب هذه نقطه الشيء الثاني ابو عاليه
حتى لو انت نتكلم مثلا دوري السنه هذه ان
صار في تغيير واسماء كبيره ومدربين حتى
النقطه اللي يمكن تناقشنا فيها ذيك الفتره
لما كان معنا نواف العقيل انه فكره انه
اليوم صار كما لو ان كل نادي في معسكرين
اللعيب الكبار اللي جايين من اوروبا
واللعيبه المحليين ذول متعودين على رتم
معين من التمارين والجهد البدني وذول
متعودين على شيء ثاني كيف مدرب اللياقه او
مدرب الفريق يقلص هذا الفارق بينهم
الاعداد البدني ما اقدر اسوي معسكر في
الصيف
ونوعيه تمارين واتوقع ان اللعيبه كلهم
بيطلعون بنفس النتيجه حتى لو كلهم كانوا
ملتزمين يعني انا احب اربط كثير باللي
يصير برا احب اربط كثير بريال مدريد شرت
كثير تتكلم عن اردا جولر اللاعب التركي
تحديدا ويقول لسه ما هو جاهز بدنيا انه في
تنافس قوي زي منافسات الليجا وفريق بدنيا
زي ريال مدريد مع انه موقع مع ريال مدريد
من الصيف صح جزء من موضوع الاصابات بس
يقول يحتاج ان احنا نشتغل عليه بدنيا عشان
بعد
فتره يصير مواكب لبقيه المجموعه نفس شغلهم
اللي مع فينيسيوس ومع رودريجو اللي
ابغى اقوله هنا ابو عاليه يعني لما سويت
تغيرات كبيره جدا في الصيف واجي عند
لاعبين متعودين على نوعيه غذاء معين نوعيه
تمارين معينه لا اتوقع ان بعد كم شهر من
بدايه الموسم نفس التوقيت اللي احنا فيه
الحين اني بلاقيهم كلهم زي بروزوفيتش مثلا
اني بلاقي عبد الله الخيبري زي بروزوفيتش
وبلاقي محمد كانو زي روبن نيفيز ترى يحتاج
انه يبني الفتره وانا في ظني ان اللعيبه
السعوديين اللي جاء هذا التغيير الكبير
جدا على منتصف مسيرتهم انا ما اتوقع منهم
حا حا كبيره في الجانب البدني تحديدا زي
ما اتوقع من اللاعبين اللي بيبد مسيرتهم
مع ه الاقلاع اللي قاعد يصير او القفزه
الكبيره اللي اللي قاعده تصير ولذلك
بتلاحظ مثلا اللعيبه اللي طلعوا مع ه
الفتره زي سعود عبد الحميد كيف انه فارق
الان باد يعيد المولد بدنيا الولد كويس
كذا لاعب يعني تشعر ان عنده هذا الجانب
وقطعا بلا شك ان هذه احنا نتكلم يمكن فصل
كثير لانه بوضوح بدنيا هذه واحده من من
اكبر مشاكلنا في المباراه ابوع في دقائق
الشوط الثاني لما المنتخب الكوري حطك تحت
الضغط هنا تتكلم عن كواليتي عالي جدا
للاعبين كم مره شفتهم ابو عاليه يلعبون
العرضيه التقليديه اللي لاعب ظهير او لاعب
طرف يعرضها يحطها بين المدافعين وتعال يا
مهاجم اسبق كل عرضياته فيها فكره العبها
على القائم البعيد وواحد يرجعها لما
اللعيبه كذا عرفت اللي انت تناظر الكوره
تروح هناك ما يمدك ترجع لهذا ارتقى وطق
بالراس لما يخترقون مع الاطراف ولا مره
يلعبها ل الحارس دام يلعبها على برا
ويحطها الواحد على القائم الثاني الفكره
انك لما تتعامل مع لاعبين بالكواليس
بلا اخطاء عشان تلعب 90 دقيقه او 100
دقيقه 120 دقيقه بلا اخطاء تحتاج انك تكون
في الدقيقه 120 بتركيز انا ما بقوللك نفس
الدقيقه الاولى لكن ما يكون في نزول كبير
هذا في التركيز اللي اهم اسبابه انك انت
تعبان انك انت مرهق انك انت تعبت على مدى
المباراه يعني ترج المباراه الاول علي
الجامي البلاي يقدر ياخذ اي ثنائيه مع سن
ومع بقيه لاعبي كوريا تجي نهايه المباراه
لا ما عاد يقدرون فعندك مشكله واضحه وكل
مره بنواجه منتخبات راحنا نتكلم اليوم عن
كوريا كاس العالم الجايه تلعب مع منتخب
اوروبي خاصه شرق اوروبا تتكلم عن بولندا
دنمارك ذو هنا ترى هنا بيبان
الموضوع مو هو عامل بدني وبقوه بدنيه يعني
هم تساموا حتى ضخمه فيفرق
كثير انا اشوف من لو خذنا من على قولتك
ابو علي نشوف من فوق على المنتخب ترى في
جوانب كثير تحسنت يعني الفتره الماضيه
والفتره الاخيره تتكلم عن منتخب او لعيبه
منتخب تطوروا كثير على الجانب التكتيكي
وفهم الاس التكتيكيه يعني شفناهم يتاقلم
على طريقه هيرفي ينار بدفاع متاخر وهير
فيار بدفاع متقدم ش بقلمون مع
ماشيني ثلاث مدافعين او خمس مدافعين وبرضه
يقلبون مع ارد في طريقه الار ا 3 وا او
حتى مع مارتك في الار ا ا او الار خوا
فتلاحظ ان البعد الفني او التكتيكي من
ناحيه التحرك من ناحيه الرسم من ناحيه
القراءه المباراه ا الخصائص الفنيه تعطى
لكل لاعب احنا تطورنا فيها بشكل مهول وفي
جانب ثاني ممكن ما ننظر لها الان لانه صار
بعد ما كان عبا علينا او كان مشكله كبيره
نعاني منها من سنوات اصبح يعني نادر ما
يكون فعلا عبا او مشكله علينا اللي هي
الكوره العرضيه اللي اللي كانت تؤرقنا
سنوات يعني اتذكر انه طلعنا من بطولات
كثير وخسرنا مباريات كثير بسبه كوره عرضيه
او ركنيه او فاول اللعب واخذ المنافس وسجل
فيه واحنا طلعنا وبعد 90 دقيقه تك لاعب
مباراه عظيمه فهذا الشيء ترى اوكي تطورنا
فيهم لكن هناك جوانب ثانيه ممكن ننظر فيها
اللي هي الجانب البدني اللي هي عمليه
خليني اقول لك فهم اللعبه انت حاجه اب علي
مهمه اثناء ما كانوا محاصر ما كانوا
يلعبون بتكنيك واحد او اسلوب واحد او فكره
فكرتين ثلاث افكار لا كانت الافكار مختلفه
فعلا كانت الافكار مختلفه مره تشوفها تنزل
لاعب الطرف يحضر اللاعب اللي جاي من
المخلف مره تشوفه اوفر القائم بعيد مره
تشوفها من ورا سعود تلعب مره تشوفها
تسديده مره تشوفها افكار كثيره وهذا يبين
لك قديش اللاعب خاض تجارب خاض منافسات
انحط في هذا الموقف مو مره ولا مرتين ولا
ثلاث حط فيه عش مرات وقدر يتعايش او
يتعاطى معه وشاف ناس حوله تتعاطى بشكل
افضل وافضل فهو يتعلم منهم لكن هذا الشيء
يعني خلينا نقول مفقود و ولا اقدر الوم
فيه اللاعبين ولكن اقدر الومهم في الاشياء
البسيطه يعني انت لما تنظر للصوره العامه
تلقى الكثير من المشاكل على صعيد اشياء
كثيره في السعوديه او المنتخب السعودي
ولكن لما ترجع ل 90 دقيقه تلقى الاخطاء
اللي صارت او او التفاصيل اللي اللي
المفروض ان احنا اذكياء فيها يعني اتذكر
لما البحرين سجلت علينا هدف هدف الفوز
اللي كان من الركنيه وشوف هدف الفوز ذا
كان الركنيه قديش كانت تقتلنا كان في
قبلها كوره احنا نقدر فيها نقتل المباراه
يعني نقدر نروح طرف الزاويه وتحضن على
الكوره وتنهي المباراه وخلاص بس عمليه
التركيز او عدم خلينا نقول الخبره وقتها
ما كان موجود عند اللاعب اللي والله ما
اتذكر حتى منهم ولا يهمني اعرف منه بس
يهمني اعرف الحاله نفسها اليوم مثلا كان
من الافضل انك في الاوقات هذه اللعيبه
اللي عندهم التجربه والخبره انت في ذك
المرحله وانا لما اقول لك يا ابو علي ان
غيرنا او تم تغيير او تم جلب بس 12 لاعب
من شرف كاس العالم ترى انت نهايه المباراه
تقريبا بلاعبين ترى يلعبون مشاركتهم
الاولى لان كثير من اللاعيبه اللي كانوا
عندهم تجارب طلعوا من المباراه فذك اللحظه
كننت تظر اللعيبه اللي زي كنوا نفس
البليهي كنت تنتظر ماشين انه ما يغامر
ويجاز باسماء ما عنده ذك التجربه كنت
انتظر يعني واحد كده يعرف كيف يمسك كوره
يعرف حتى لو كان بيطلع الكره وشتتها
يشتتها في مكان او
بعيد او في منطقه فيها خلينا نقول نسبه
لاعبين السعودين اكثر عشان بدك تضغط بدك
تطلع من مناطقك ما شفت هذا الشي يعني
تقريبا اخر عش دقائق اللي هي الوقت الضايع
حرفيا كانت الكره تروح ثم ترجع علينا تروح
ثم كما لو ان ننتظر هدف وكان في خطوره
يعني اكثر منكم في العارضه حده اللي اللي
مادري ش طلعها حسان على مره ف خليني
اقوللك اني انا مغبون من الخساره ولا كنت
ابغى انه انه نطلع من ه البطوله تحديدا
بهذه الطريقه لانه لانه لو رحنا ابعد من
كذا ممكن قادرين نوصل الى مستوى متقدم
ولكن يخليني كده ارجع شوي واقول الله عين
ك كوريا على المباراه الجايه يعني كوريا
راح تلعب المباراه الجايه راحه ثلاث ايام
استراليا مرتاحه خمس ايام والكوريا للاعب
مباراه بدنيه 120 دقيقه ضد منتخب يعني من
اقوى المنتخبات في اسيا واستراليا للاعبه
مع اضعف المنتخبات في اسيا هنا يرجعها ترى
العمليه خلينا نقول نظام البطوله اللي
اللي هو ظالم وظلمنا احنا وكوريا ام ترى
لما تنحط في جروبات اسيا في المجموعه
السادسه والخامسه انت حرفيا حظك حظك ردي
يك تطيح مع ثاني المجموعه رقم خمسه ورقم
خمسه الاول بيطيح مع ثاني مجموعه رقم سته
ف لا الاخير انت شفت المباراه ل الظهر
اوزباكستان وتايلاند يعني تخيل واحد من
ذول يوصل دور الثمانيه وتضطر انك تضحي
يعني السعوديه وكوريا
لانه الاول مع الثاني بينما هناك ثاني
يلعب مع ثاني او ثاني يلعب مع مع ث يمكن
تكلمت عن ذا الموضوع ابو علي اللي هو
موضوع 24 منتخب لكن خليني ارجع انت تكلمت
عن مانشيني ا انا اعتقد انه قبل ما اتكلم
عن مانشيني لابد ان بكل امانه وتجرد نواجه
واقعنا اللي احنا موجودين فيه اليوم اليوم
انت تتنافس في قاره مع منتخبات صفوه
لاعبيها ونجومها هم لاعبين محترفين معظمهم
لاعبين في النصف المتقدم من الملعب او
خلينا نقول في الثلث الهجومي كوريا اليوم
خط دفاعهم عندهم مدافع في بايرن ميونخ
والبقيه جايين من اولسان بس تطلع من
المحاور وقدام تلقى صفوه اللاعبين اللي
يلعب في توتنهام اللي يلعب في ولفرهامبتون
اللي يلعب في باريس سان جيرمان صفه لاعبين
موجودين في الثلث الهجومي تجي مثلا
لليابان ممكن انا وياك ما نعرف اسماء
مدافعين يابانيين كثير بس نعرف كوبو ونعرف
مينا مينو
ونعرف ميتو ونعرف ان افضل اللاعبين الم
موجودين عندهم هم لاعبين ثلث هجومي نفس
الكلام ينطبق على سردار ومهدي ارمي في
ايران افضل لاعبيه موجودين في الثلث
الهجومي اللعيبه ثقال اللي ممكن يخلصوا لك
مباراه تجي للمنتخب السعودي الواقع اليوم
والواقع اللي انت بتكمل عليه كذا سنه قدام
ان لاعبيك في هذا المركز اللاعبين اللي
يصنعون الفارق المركز اللي كان يلعب فيه
سامل جابر وماجد عبد الله ويوسف الثني
فد الريفي لا اتكلم عن اللعيبه اللي في
كاس اسيا وكاس العالم وسعيد العويران
وخالد مسعد صفوت لاعبيك الجيل اللي كلنا
نتذكرهم الواقع اليوم ان لاعبيك يلعبون في
هذه
المراكز يا الله تطلع لك واحد يلعب اساسي
في نادي معظمهم بدلاء في انديتهم يعني
الوحيد اللي اليوم مثلا يلعب في ناديه
سالم مع بقيه عناصر اللي موجوده في الهلال
ما عندك ولا مهاجم يلعب فيراس لان فرمينو
سي فرمينو ما كان سي فيراس ما كان راح
يلعب ا في الاهلي عبد الرحمن غريب بديل
عبد الله رديف بديل صالح الشهري بديل كل
عناصرك في هذا ولا تتوقع ان هذا الحال
بيتغير خلال السنوات الجايه بالتالي انا
في منافسه اني خلك من يتاهل كاس العالم
ثمام منتخبات الان سه المفروض انك انت
لازم تكون في كاس العالم الجايه بس عشان
اسوي شيء في كاس العالم وعشان اسوي شيء في
كاس اسيا 2017 هل انا بسويه لاني املك
عناصر ما بقول افضل زي اللي عن اليابان
وكوريا وايران واستراليا فعل انا ما راح
اسويها لعناصر افضل من عناصر الجماعه
قاعدين يتقدمون لاعبيهم قاعدين يروحون
اتكلم يمكن ابو علي المناس تكلمت على
موضوع احتراف اللاعبين خارجيا بعد كاس
العالم الماضي ولازال عندي نفس الراي لكن
خلينا نقول اليوم الموضوع صار صعب مره بعد
التطور الكبير اللي صار في الدوري وصار
عندك دوري بامانه زي ما قال رونالدو افضل
من الدوري
الفرنسي اذا اذا ما قلنا ان افضل بنقول
افضل ست سبع دوريات على مستوى العالم
بالتالي عندك دوري قوي وتنافسي لعبتك
يلعبون فيه بس المشكله ان لاعبيك ما
يلعبون فيه اساسي بشكل اساسي ولا عندك نجم
سوبر ستار موجود في الثلث الهجومي اليوم
كلنا كنا مبسوطين من اداء علي الا جامي
وكلنا مبسوطين من اداء علي البليهي بس ليش
لانهم هم اللي يلعبون اساسيا في انديتهم
مبسوطين من اداء عبد الله الخيبري هم
يلعبون اساسيا في انديتهم سعود عبد الحميد
وغيرهم بس انت قدام ما عندك لاعبين بنفس
الكواليتي بالتالي انا عشان اتفوق على
المنتخبات هذه بتفوق لاني املك عناصر افضل
ولا لاني تكتيكيا افضل لاحظ قبل شوي لما
تكلمت ابو عالي عن عن كوريا وعن تغيير
الافكار انت تكلمت عن اللاعبين والتجارب
ما جب طاري كلينسمان وانا وياك والمتابع
عندنا اعتقاد ان كنزمان ما له علاقه في
الموضوع ان كلينسمان لو الموضوع ترك ل
دهاء كلينز منان وتغييرات كلينز منان ك ما
كانت راح تفوز بس انت عندك لاعبين اوكي
انت بتعطيهم تعليمات بس هم من انفسهم
يعرفون يتصرفون في الملعب هل انت تملك
لاعبين قياديين يعرفون يتص رفون في الملعب
يكسبون ك الواقع لا شلون اكسب اكسب لاني
فريق منظم وتكتيكي مين اللي بيوصلني لاني
اكون فريق منظم وتكتيكي هو مدرب زي
مانشيني يشتغل كثير على الجانب البدني
يشتغل كثير على التنظيم يشتغل كثير على
الجانب الخططي واقعيا كاس اسيا المفروض يا
ابو عالي انها تكون في باكج واحد مع كاس
العالم البطولتين بينها 11 شهر ولولا ان
كاس كاس اسيا الحاليه
اعتذرت عن استضافتها الصين ترى كانت بتلعب
في الصيف الماضي يعني بعد ست شهور من كاس
العالم هي بعد ست شهور حفيا فعليا فانت
لما تجي تبني خططك وا استراتيجيتك المفروض
انك تروح تلعب كاس العالم وبعدها بسنه نفس
الفريق هذا تروح تشارك فيه في كاس العالم
القادمه اللي انا ابغى اقوله ان مانشيني
جاء في الفتره هذه لا وما جاء في اولها
جاء في اخرها فبالتالي ما كان عنده وقت
انه يقدر ان يطبع الفريق بكل الافكار اللي
موجوده عنده لكن له بصمه واضحه له تاثير
واضح ان نغير نلعب كاس العالم 2022 بمدرب
ونلعب كاس اسيا 23 بمدرب ونبحث عن مدرب
جديد يدربنا في 26 ترى كماله ان نبني اهدم
نبني اهدم عمرك ما راح تتطور كذا را وعمرك
ما راح توصل لاهدافك لابد ان تواجه واقعك
الى انك انت عشان تكسب انت ما راح تكسب
لانك تضم اللاعبين الافضل انت بتكسب لانك
تضم الفريق الاقوى الاقوى وتكلم من جانبها
البدني كلح كروح كضباط ولذلك ماشيني اذا
كان صارر في موضوع الانضباطيه هذا واحد من
اكثر الاسباب ترى اللي بتنجح الفتره
الجايه في منتخبات يا ابو عاليه حتى لو في
فاوضه عندك عناصر تكسبك حتى لو في مشاكل
عندك عناصر تكسبك حتى لو دفاعك تعبان
حارسك دايخ عندك خط هجومي يكسبك احنا ما
احنا هذا المنتخب احنا المنتخب اللي اذا
بيكسب بيكسب لانه منضبط ملتزم الروح داخل
المعسكر ايجابيه اللعيبه كلهم قلبهم على
المنتخب وترى لاعبينا اظهروا هالجانب صحيح
يعني حسان تمبكتي تفوق على نفسه لما لعب
ضد الارجنتين علي جامي في مباراه كوريا
وانا قاعد اتابع اقول اذا مدافعهم يلعب في
بايرن ميونخ ل جا المفروض يلعب جنبه في
بايرن ميونخ ولا يلعب في فريق كبير على
اداء اللي قدمه في مباراه اليوم لما تجي
المنافسات الكبرى زي كاس العالم ومباراه
بهذه القيمه في كاس اسيا يجيني شعور ان
كثير من لعيبه المنتخب قاعدين يتفوقون على
انفس قاعد يوريني اداء انا اقول هذا عبد
الله الخيبري انا قاعد اشوفه في الدوري
هذا سعود عبد الحميد اللي قاعدين نتابعه
وفي بعض الايان يكون عنده مشاكل مع الهلال
معناته ايش هو ليش يعطيك هال الاداء ليش
احمد الكسار يظهر بهذا الشكل لانه عنده
رغبه لانه عنده روح لان الاجواء داخل
المعسكر ايجابيه هذه الاشياء المكتسبات
اللي عندك تحاول انك تحافظ عليها وتطور
جوانب الضعف اللي عندك لكن فكره انك كل
مره تبحث عن سبب بسيط تعلق الخساره عليه
لو حط التغيير لو سوى لو فعل لو ثم تهدم
وتبني مره ثانيه اكيد انه جزء ترى من
الغضب على مانشيني هي تصريحات اللي كانت
قبل البطوله جزء منها المشهد غير الجيد
لما طلع من الملعب ولسه كان في ركله وترى
في مشهد الناس ترى ما انتب وانا في ظني
انه اسوا من خروجه من الملعب رث لما على
نهايه الشوط الثاني اللعيبه طالعين خلاص
راح اشواط اضافيه فجت الكاميرا عليه يكلم
عبد الرحمن غريب قال لله واي بعدين كذا ما
كان واضح الصوت كان واضح انه يعاتب على
العرضيه اللي جاء منها الهدف وبعدين جا
بعد سعود وقال سعود كذا يبي يكمل عتب سعود
حبيبي الحكم صفر رايح شواط اضافيه الكلام
في اللي فات ما راح يفيد حفز لعيبت حفزهم
خلاص ان الواقع انك انت رايح شواط اضافيه
ش يفيد انك تعاتب اللاعبين الحين ش يفيد
انك تصحح خلاص اللي صار صار حفز لاعبيك
وحك تهيم نفسيا ومعنويا لشوط المباراه
الاضافي في اخطاء جزء منها من اللاعبين
جزء منها من الاتحاد اللي تاخر في عمليه
حسب موضوع المدرب وجزء منها من ماشيني هل
اتعامل مع هذه الاخطاء اني اصححها ولا
اقول يلا اهدم وابن من جديد انا اعتقد انه
كثره التغيير ما راح تفيدنا وحتى لو انا
بمشي مانشيني انا احتاج مدرب زي مانشيني
يعرف ينجح باقل الادوات يعرف ينجح
بكواليتي لاعبين انت لما تروح تلعب انت ما
انت افضل منافس ولا انت اول مرشح ولا تملك
افضل سكواد ولا تملك افضل نجوم تحتاج مدرب
يتعامل وفقا لهذا الاساس يعني من الخيارات
اللي كانت مطروحه في الصيف جيسوس جيسوس في
كل تجاربه مع الهلال وفلامينجو وبنفيكا
كان دائما يدرب افضل او من بين افضل
اللاعبين الموجودين في الدوري اللي هو
يدربه اليوم لو انا اجيب مدرب جيسوس او
واحد زي جيسوس تعامل مع حقيقه ان اللاعبين
اللي انت تملكهم هم ليسوا الافضل منافسك
عندهم لاعبين احسن منك شلون بتنجح و
منافسك عندهم لاعبين احسن منك هذا هو
التحدي عشان تفوز بهال التحدي لازم تعطي
مهو 100% على قوله تمشيني ن قوم يعطي 200%
حص لازم لا لازم بعد تكون قادر لازم تعطي
200% لازم تكون قادر اكيد انك لازم تكون
قادر بس انك لازم تعطي اكبر م ما عندك
وعشان تقلل من هذه الفوارق اللي بينك وبين
البقيه وترى ماشيني ما عمل الشي الغلط لما
راحن على قوه الدفاع ورهانه على قوه
الدفاع ورهانه على اني اني يكون فريقي
ملتزم دفاعيا يكون فريقي صعب انك تسجل
عليه دفاعيا هو الرهان الصح لانه حرفيا
انت ما تملك اللاعب المؤثر او اللاعب ذو
الجوده العاليه قدام فانت رهانك لازم يكون
او الاد فاليو الميزه الاضافيه حق منتخبك
لازم تكون في قوه دفاع ودائما الطرف او
المنتخب الاقل او النادي الاقل ترشيحا او
المستضعف على على قولتهم هو المنتخب اللي
ما يكون مم المناطقه ويلعب على المرتده في
تجربه اليونان في تجارب كثيره حتى في
مبرايات اللي بين نادي كبير ونادي اقل
تلقي النادي الاقل دائما هو اللي شويه
يدافع ويركز على التفاصيل تفاصيل ركنيات
كور ثابته مرتدات ايا تكن وتسجل من خلالها
انا ممكن يا ابو
عليما افكر في ماشيني وفي مستقبل ماشيني
وهل فعلا ناخذ الشخص الخطا في الطريق الصح
وناخذ الشخص الصح في الطريق الخطا هذا هو
السؤال اللي ممكن انه شوي انا يوترني لكن
لما اجي اشوف التجربه واقيس عليها تجربه
ايرفي رينارد كان هو الشخص الصح في
الطريقه الصح يعني اخذنا المرحله تقريبا
احنا كانت افضل مشاركه لنا في المديات
السابقه الخمس كانت هذه السادسه بعد 94
لما اجي اشوف ماشيني والوقت الضيق اللي
اخذ فيه المنتخب وعمليه حتى تعاطيه مع مع
المنتخب الوطني وكفاحه في حضور المباريات
مراقبه الكل التفاصيل عن الرجل حرفيا كان
جالس هنا في الرياض فتره طويله يحضر كل
المباريات حضر مباريات مختلفه وخلينا نقول
تعرف على على اهم اللاعبين وافضل انا اقدر
اقوللك ان هذه افضل مشاركه لان من بعد
2007 اوكي 2011 كارثيه 2015 اسو واسو
2 19 اللي كانت في الامارات ما كان في ذاك
المستوى الفني رم ان يعني كان منتخبنا
يمشي في ليفل كويس بس ها تقريبا هي
المشاركه الافضل وطلعنا من المنتخب قوي و
كان بينه وبين الصعود 50 ثانيه وركلات
ترجيع في نهايه الامر فاعتقد ان الحكم على
ماشيني من ناحيه انه انه احنا نهدم اللي
بناه لا اعطيه فرصته لانه هذا الشيء اللي
وراني اياه الان في الفتره القصيره هذه
يعطيني اعجاب انه هو فاهم اصلا انه ليس
منتخب او الطرف اللي دايم بيكون مبادر مو
الطرف اللي دايم بيكون الافضل من ناحيه
تعاطي مع البطولات هذه او حتى في القاره
نفسها التعاطي مع المنتخبات اللي معك في
القاره ما بالك لو تلعب في بطوله كاس
العالم فلو تقريبا لو اخذ هذه الفتره او
اخذ حزمه من الزمن ممكن حتى في ذه الفتره
يطلع لك كم لاعب وحتى في مساله وهذا الشيء
انا ابغاه يكون يعني في اذن كل اللاعبين
تبغى تمثل منتخب وطني تبغى تلعب بشكل
اساسي ترى ممكن تلعب في نادي كبير وبرستيج
انك تلعب في نادي كبير وال جماهيريه
والبطولات بس انت في حرفيا ترى كل اللي
بتلعبه 300 دقيقه في الموسم ما تجاوز ث
مباريات اربع مباريات اتكلم عن مجمل دقائق
تراك تقدر تلعبها في نادي اقل ودقائق اكثر
ومستواك يرتفع ويرتفع لان المنافسين تلعب
معاهم هم الطرف الاقوى فانت تستقبل منهم
تتعلم منهم في نفس الوقت انت عليك عليك
الضغط لانك انت في ارض الملعب تلعب ما انت
في الدكه جالس عشان كده انا قلتلك اني كنت
من الناس اللي مؤيد القرار تقليص قائمه كل
نادي ل 25 لاعب لانه بخلي لاعبين كثير
يطلعون من انديتهم ويجدون فرصه في انديه
اخرى اتوقع ابو عالي الحديث عن
مانشيني ما ابغى اعطي نسبه لكن شريحه
كبيره جدا من الناس اللي عندهم مشكله مع
مانشيني هو بسبب تصرفات وليس بسبب قراراته
كمدرب او خيارات الفنيه اللي كانت في
المباريات الماضيه سواء على مستوى الاسماء
او حتى على
مستوى التبديلات وتدخلاتها في المباراه
وانما في الصداميه اللي بدات بالمؤتمر
الشهير اللي هو سواه مرورا بالتصرف اللي
صار وقت البلنتيات ان هناك دائما شعور انه
المدرب هذا يسوي اشياء تستفزنا احنا
والمشكله لما تصير انه في صداميه ما بين
المدرب والاعلام والجمهور بتحتاج الى انك
تكسب رضاهم او خلينا نقول تقنعهم خلال
الفتره الجايه وما عندك استحقاق مهم جدا
لتصفيات كاس العالم اللي لما ندخل على
مراحلها النهائيه يعني نحتاج الى وقت من
العالم لذلك اعتقد انه المسؤوليه حاليا هي
مسؤوليه الاتحاد السعودي استاذ ياسر
المسحل اذا كان يرى ويعتقد واتوقع ان هذه
وجهه نظره ان المدرب هو مشروع طويل الامد
لابد انه يكون في حمايه للمدرب حمايه انت
ما تقدر تمنع الناس انها تنتقد ولا تقدر
تمنع الناس انها تبدي ارائها لكن حمايه
بمعنى انك تجدد الثقه فيه تعطي رسائل ان
المدرب عندي معه مشروع واني انا اثق فيه
واني اشعر ان هو المدرب المناسب للفتره
القادمه يمكن ماشين هذه اول تجربه له في
المنطقه العربيه يحتاج شوي انه يفهم
حساسيه تعاطينا كاعلام وجمهور مع المنتخب
حساسيه انك تطلع وتكلم وتقول ان في لاعبين
رفضوا الانضمام للمنتخب الموضوع بالنسبه
لنا ابدا ما هو بعادي فبالتالي انا اقول
انه الاستحقاق زي كاس امم بكل ما فيه من
تحديات كونه في قطر قريب منا فبالتالي
الجماهير تسافر باعداد كبيره والصحفيين
باعداد كبيره وكمال انك انت قاعد تلعب
يعني على على ارضك وبين جمهورك فبالتالي
كانت واحده من المشاكل بالنسبه مانشيني
انك بعد اقل ثلاث اربع شهور لقيت نفسك في
حدث بهذه الضخامه وبامانه تعامل مانشيني
مع كثير من تفاصيله ممكن ما كانت مثاليه
لكن ارجع واقول انا لست مع الهدم نحتاج
انه نتعامل مع مشاكلنا بواقعيه ونحتاج انه
نبطل نعطي اسباب سهله
وساذج وبدائي للتعثر
مشاكلنا اعمق من ذلك في جزء منها هو واقع
انت لابد ان تتعامل معه اليوم وجزء منها
يحتاج الى حلول بس الحلول هذه تحتاج انك
على مدى بعيد الى انك انت توجد لها حل
يعني ما اعتقد انه الان وقت مناسب انك
تتكلم مثلا عن ضروره وجود محترفين في
الخارج ضروره محترفي وجود محترفين في
الخارج
يحتاج انك تطلع جيل جديد والجيل الجديد
هذا يبدا يلعب في انديه على على مستوى
اوروبا اقل ثم بعد ذلك يصعد اليوم دوريك
المحلي نجح بامانه انه يقدم لك لاعبين على
مستوى البدني
واللياقية بطوله امم اسيا في خط دفاع افضل
منه ليش لانهم يحتكون واحد يلعب جنب
لابورت واحد يلعب جنب كوليبالي واححد ظهير
يلعب قدامه مالكم يفرق معك يطور انت كلاعب
حتى تلعب لكن اي لكن تحتاج الى انه في
بقيه مراكز اللعب يكون عندك نفس الكواليتي
وذه ارجع اقوللك في اشياء تحتاج الى حلول
طويله الامد منها زي ما قلنا تقليس قوائم
الانديه انا مع ان الدوري صار 34 جوله ومع
ان كاس الملك ودوري ابطال اسيا كل ما تكثر
مباريات كل ما يصير عندك مباراتين كل
اسبوع انت عشان كفريق انا عندي 25 لاعب
وعندي في الموسم 50 60 مباراه بتسلف لعيبه
من بره لازم اعدهم بدنيه عشان يقدرون
يغطون لي هالعدد من
المنافسات بالتالي اعدادي لهم في الصيف
ونوعيه تمارينهم وتغذيتهم تسعى الى انهم
يكونون جاهزين ويلعبون مباراتين كل اسبوع
مباراه كل ثلاث ايام اللي هو نفس الواقع
اللي انت تواجه لما تروح تلعب في كاس
العالم وكاس امم اسيا لكن اللي قاعد عد
يصير حاليا لما نروح نلعب هذا الكم من
المباريات في وقت قصير يبان انه احنا
بدنيا ما احنا جاهزين وعدد كبير ابو علي
وقطع كلامك من المباريات
يقابله عدد قليل من اللعيب يعني تقليص عدد
القوائم الى 25 اسم وخلينا نقول ممكن توصل
عدد المباريات عندنا الى ما بين 50 الى 55
مباراه اتذكر السيتي الموسم الماضي وصلت
عد عدد المباريات لما اخذ الثلاثيه 60
مباراه انت قلت مع جانب مهم ابو علي ن قلز
من وشيني الاثنين اللي في الدكه ذولي نلزم
كلينسمان ومشيني كلينسمان لما فكر بس فكر
اللي هي قبل المباراه ولعب الثلاث مدافعين
حاس فريق او منتخب كوريا حوس بهالطريقه
لخبط كل شيء لانه كانت انتقالات كلها على
الاربعه ار ا لما بس رجع وخلى الفريق يلعب
بطريقه اللي هي المعتاده في اوروبا اللي
هي ار الار ا 3 وا او الار 3 3 الفريق
خلينا نقول الشوط الثاني اكل الجيم يعني
ترى الشوط الثاني حرفيا يا ابو علي 91
نسبه استحواذ الكوريا تقريبا عدد الباصات
اللي لعبوها 291 باص في المقابل احنا 124
باص يعني عمليه الضغط وال الافتكاسه اللي
عملوها ما كانت بسبه ان المدرب هو يزمان
اللي في الدكه كانت بسببه انه عنده لاعبين
بجوده عاليه على النقيد تماما في في
ماشيري في جوانب كثير ترح حلو في المنتخب
وانا والله مبسوط منها مو هو الفتره
الحاليه ولكن الفتره القريبه الماضيه
اتكلم عن الخمس سنوات الماضيه منتخبنا ترى
في صعود يعني ما احنا كنا نطلع في تصفيات
كاس العالم في البرازيل من الدور الاول
ودي كارثه بالنسبه لناي ولا حتى في
تعاطينا مع كاس العالم 2018 وتقريبا فتره
مفك كانت مثاليه جدا بس احنا جاسين نرتقي
وارتقائه بالمنافسه جاس يعطي ترى المنتخب
السعودي قيمه ومكانه عند اللاعب ترى مهم
يكون المنتخب قيمه ترى فتره من فترات
ماكان المنتخب عند اللعيب السعوديين اللي
موجودين في في الدوري السعودي ما يهمي
يروح يلعب على المتخب منتخب ولا لا لانه
يدري في هايه المطاف انه منتخب غير مرشح
وانه ليس مطالب بشيء وانه وان الناس اصلا
ما هي مهتمه لمباراه المنتخب في فتره من
الزمن ما تكلم عن فتره بعيده ترى قبل اذا
كانت بالكثير ف قبل 10 سنوات الان تغير
الموضوع صار في زخم على المنتخب صار في
مشجعين يحضرون في كل مكان صار في شوي حاله
خلقت تجاه المنتخب الوطني وهذه الحاله
تخلي اللاعب لما يلعب قميص المنتخب يبدل
قصار جهده عشان ينافس وعشان يسعد هذه
الجماهير شرف الوطن بلا شك انا ودي في
الختام ابو عاليه اني اتوجه بالشكر لكل
مشجع تكبد يعني عناء السفر الى قطر حضور
المباريات ارجع واقول
ان مشهد ملعب ممتلئ لك في كل مباراه
وبطوله تقام خارج ارضك حتى لو كانت في
دوله مجاوره يظل فيه يعني اجراءات في
التنقل تذاكر طيران ايجاد سكن ايجاد سياره
لو انت رايح طيران كثير من التفاصيل اللي
اسهل لك كيخ انك انت تتابع وانت في البيته
قطع من العذاب اب بالضبط وممكن تعودنا انه
الولاءات الكبيره هذه تكون عند المشجعين
تجاه انديتهم هذا ترى موجود في كل مكان في
العالم ان الناس غالبا الانتماء الكبير
يكون يعني او الانتماء اللصيق او الشيء
تحس الليك انت اللي انت اخترته او اللي
انت يمثلك هو انتماءك لناديك المنتخب
السعودي على مدى تاريخه كان يروح يلعب في
الامارات و في قطر تكلم عن تصفيات كاس
العالم او تكلم عن بطولات اسيا اللي اقيمت
اكثر من مره في الامارات وفي قطر ما عمر
المنتخب كان يحظى بهذا الحضور الجماهيري
الا في كاس العالم الماضي و كاس امم اسيا
الحاليه جزء من الموضوع
بامانه يعود الاتحاد السعودي التسهيلات
الكبيره جدا اللي قدموها للجمهور
والمشجعين اللي كانوا يعني يؤمنوا لهم
رحلات من اجل حضور ومسانده المباريات
الاخضر ولكن الجزء الكبير هم اللي قرروا
هم بانفسهم انهم يسافرون خلف هذا المنتخب
يعطيكم الف عافيه شكرا جزيلا لكم كنتم
والله العظيم ملح البطوله وجمال البطوله
واديتهم اللي عليكم وكنتم محفزين والرابطه
ما تسكت طول المباراه والجمهور انا حضرت
في الملعب يشجع طوال المباراه رجال ونساء
كبار وصغار هذول ما لهم علاقه في كل اللي
قاعد يصير ما لهم علاقه في قرارات مدرب
ولا لهم علاقه في خطا لاعب ولا لهم علاقه
في استراتيجيه اتحاد هذا الدور اللي مطلوب
من
سواه وزياده فمان نقول لهم شكرا يعطيكم
الف عافيه حظ اوفر لنا ولكم وان شاء الله
يا رب انه القادم افضل المنتخب السعودي
والله ما قصر صراحه يعني انا قلتلك السفر
قطع من العذاب ولما تكون في مكان بعيد عن
عائلتك سواء اذا كنت عندك اولاد او امك
وابوك او حتى المصاريف اللي تصرفها او حتى
يعني العناء نفسه من ناحيه التشجيع ترى
يطلعون والمسيره تبدا من قبل مبراه باربع
خمس ساعات
وجهد وهم ما شاء الله عليهم يعني حتى
اثناء المباراه ولا في في براحه الجنوب
كانوا يعني معطين اجواء جدا رائعه شرفونا
شرفوا المشجع السعودي اعطوا المشجع
السعودي قيمه العالم شافه المشجع السعودي
واتذكر في تجربه كاس العالم كانت مقاطع
كثير في كل مكان تنشر وفي كل القنوات وفي
كل منصات على عن المشجعين السعوديين
تقريبا اشهرنا كثير من الكلمات ويرز مسي
وغيرها في التشجيع امس شوف حتى لاعبي
منتخب الاردن بعد المباراه يعني يا اخي
انت اليوم يعني الدوله راس راس مال كره
القدم بالنسبه لك هو المشجع الاستثمار
الكبير اللي قاعده تسويه الدوله في
الرياضه السعوديه لان اللعبه الشعبيه
الاولى لانه موجود هذا الشغف عندنا تجاه
تجاه اللعبه استشعار اللاعبين للمسؤوليه
لانه عندهم لاعبين المنتخب تكلم تحيد لانه
وراهم هال الجمهور خلفهم جمهور وخلف يرغب
ان بالمزيد والمزيد وهذا النجاح اصلا
بيكتب في اسمك نهايه الامر انت جاي بعد
فتره وحقبه زمنيه طويله ترى ما فيها
انجازات وممكن ممكن اختم كلامي يا ابو علي
هذه الحلقه اللي انا ما احب صراحه اني
اطلع بعد الخساره بالذات اذا كانت يعني في
كاس العالم او في كاس اسيا تصفيات كاس
العالم ممكن نقدر نتدارك الموضوع صحيح
لانها مؤذيه لي انا شخصيا لاني انا والله
احتاج فرحه احس اني من زمان ترى ما فرحت
يعني اخر فرحه عشتها مع المنتخب السعودي
ممكن الفوز على ارجنتين النهائي اسي لما
وصلنا نها اسف في 2007 ولكن حرفيا اخر
فرحه كانت 96 و96 انا ما ودي اقوللك كم
عمري ولكن كنت جدا صغير في السن اللي
جرسني اتذكر لمحات منها فهذا الجمهور اللي
يحضر كل يوم او يحضر في كل المنافسات ترى
يبغى هذه الفرحه اللي غابت فتره طويله
والتحدي الان انه ما نهدم الاشياء السابقه
العمل يبدا من اليوم الى كاس العالم 2026
الى كاس اسيا 20 27 لانها هي اللحظه اللي
المفروض نكون احنا فيها مرشحين لا مرشحين
بقوه ان نجيب هذا مرشح اول كمان ليه لانك
اوريدي انت جاز تبني هذا المنتخب ضحيت في
هذه البطوله خلنا نقولك ضحيت فيها لو كنت
قلتلي ما ضحيت انا متاكد انك ضحيت فيها
اتخذت فيها قرارات جريئه صنعت فيها خط او
مسافه بين اللاعب والمنتخب وحطيت لك ضحايا
هذول الضحايا شافهم كل الناس صنعت صدام
بينك وبين الجمهور خلينا نقولك حاولت تخلق
هاله للمنتخب انه اي واحد بيقرب ترى بيجيه
نفس الشي وازود فهذه مجرد ضحايا ودائما
تخلق اي حاله نظام تسيطر على اي مجموعه من
اشخاص في اي مكان ما لازم يكون عندك ضحايا
ولازم يكون عندك نظام ولازم يكون عندك
خطوط حمراء لا يمكن تتجاوز وهذا الشيء
خلقته راهنت على لعيبه صغار في ارض الملعب
راهنت على مدرب يحمل افكار مختلفه وبدلا
انها تقريبا جز تحل الكثير من مشاكل
المنتخب السعودي لا على الصعيد الاسماء
الموجوده ولا على صيد حتى العرضيات او
الاشياء كانت تجينا منها او كانت تمسنا في
البطالات السابقه يعني نادر الان ماشوف
هدف علينا يكون من العرضيه فرانك هذا اللي
انت اخذته زائد انك فقط عندك في التشكيله
او القائمه اللي رحت فيها كاس اسيا س س
لعيبه فوق 30 سنه يعني تقريبا 24 اسم او
عفوا 20 اسم اقل من من 30 سنه ونسبه كبيره
منهم اقل من 24 سنه فانت الان جالس تبني
او تخلق منظومه ما فيها مشاكل منظومه يجب
ان يحترمها كل شخص يدخلها منظومه منضبطه
100% منظومه تعمل تكتيكيا وفق مدرب خلينا
نقول يحاول يقلل المسافات بينه وبين
منافسيه ويحاول يستفيد من الميزه الاضافيه
او الشيء الاضافي اللي المنتخب يتميز فيه
او لعيبه المنتخب يتميزون فيه ان يقل
الفجوه بينه وبين منتخبات القاره فاعتقد
ان الاربع سنوات الجايه مع قرار 25 لاعب
مع
ايضا كثره منافسات وجود دوري قوي المفروض
ان تخلينا ابطل وبطل لكاس اسيا ان شاء
الله باذن الله نكون اياك في الملعب ابو
علي
نحتفل بالبطوله ان شاء الله باذن الله
تعالى ابو علي هل انت صديق لمن شيني بقوه
انا احبه لا صديق تهمه لك ترى اذا انت
تقول انك انت صديق المنشي معنات انك تقول
اراك بدافع الصداقه يعني لا لا مو صديق
انا مؤمن ان
ماشيني رجل قادر انه يحل كثير مشاكل لانه
كان دائما ما يخذلني يعني نادر ما يخذلني
المباراه طل الكوره فوز خساره انت في
النهايه ممكن ممكن صح انت لو خسرت ثلاثه
اربعه مستواك كارثي انا هنا اقول لك انت
جبت العيد فيني بس انت خسرت واح ص0 و عفوا
رك الترجيح والتعادل جاب في اخر 50 ثانيه
فانت ما قصرت والفوارق بيني وبين هذا
المنتخب مو اي منتخب ما لعبت مع مع
تايلاند ولا لعبت مع جرجستان لعبت منتخب
ترى قوي منتخب مرشح يجيب بطوله فحين اقول
بيض الله وجهك ما قصرت
واعتقد انه الرجل
مناسب المقصد انك لا انت صديق المشيني ولا
انا يا ابو عاليه
واضح انحت شكلي فما في اي مصلحه من انك
تقول يعني اي راي تجاه منشين تجاه المرحله
المقبله لاي سبب كان الا لانك تعتقد ان
مصلحه كره القدم السعوديه هي ان تواصل
البناء على الشيء او الشغل اللي موجود
حاليا وكثير من الاهداف اللي انت تبغى
توصلها ترى تحتاج الى انك تتعثر مره
ومرتين وثلاث حتى تصل اليها افضل
المنتخبات اليوم على مستوى العالم
المنتخبات تفوز بكاس العالم تفوز بكاس امم
اوروبا هي نتيجه بناء الكثير منها يضطر
انهم يبنون جيل الناشئين شباب منتخب اول
يتعثرون مره يتعثرون مرتين وبعد ذلك يصلون
منتخب فرنسي اللي فاز بكاس العالم 2018 هو
نفسه اللي خسر نهائي البطوله 2016 على
ارضه وبين جمهوره امام البرتغال الارجنتين
اللي فازت بكاس العالم الاخيره هي من خسرت
النهائي امام المانيا في
2014 الفشل هو جزء من طريقك للنجاح المهم
انك انت تجيد تقييمك للمرحله تجيد وضع
اصبعك على مكان من الخلل وبعد ذلك تبدا
انك تتخذ الحلول اللي ممكن تصحح الوضع في
المرحله القادمه شكرا لك ابو علالي شكرا
لك اب واضح اني شطحت قبل شوي بحق منشين مو
صديقي ولا ولا يمتلي ولا صديق ولا نتكلم
ايطالي ولا نكتو
ورا كراتس يا ابو ع كرات يا
ابوس شكرا لك وشكرا لمحمد الفوزان في
اعداد وانتاج هذه الحلقه عبد الرحمن عبود
في التصوير وفي الاضاءه ياسر كدشه في
التسجيل والهندسه الصوتيه عبد العزيز
المزي وفي التحرير مرام الطبيبان وفي
التلوين احمد سالم وفي اداره الانتاج عبد
المجيد عمر وفي اداره محتوى التواصل
الاجتماعي احمد غالب هذا بودكاست مرتدى
احد منتجات الشركه الثمانيه للنشر
والتوزيع نلتقيكم باذن الله تعالى مطلع
الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
القادم